hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
sunscreen obsessed
one of the big misconceptions is how
sunscreens work
in particular chemical versus physical
sunscreens
i've debunked this a whole bunch of
times before and i have a video talking
about the more technical details behind
how both chemical
and physical sunscreens absorb uv but
then i realized i could actually test
this in real life
and maybe it'll be a little bit more
convincing if you like this sort of
nerdy beauty content click the like the
subscribe and the notification bell so
you don't miss any videos
[Music]
so like i said before both chemical and
physical sunscreens mostly work
by taking uv and converting it to a
harmless amount of heat
physical sunscreens also scatter about
five percent of the incoming uv
the sun's energy is also about 53
infrared
which converts heat directly on our skin
and only about three to seven percent is
uv
so if most of that tiny amount of uv is
converted to heat
and there's only a small amount of
difference in that tiny amount of uv
there really shouldn't be much of a
difference but some people have
questioned whether that tiny tiny amount
of heat
is enough to make a difference so i
decided to test out what happens in
reality
so conveniently i found out that my boss
alex who is a former optics professor
actually owns an infrared camera this
takes photos that show
things at different temperatures as
different colors and you can see
down to about a one degree celsius
difference so i convinced him to help me
do some measurements with sunscreen to
see if we could see any interesting
differences
so he took a bunch of different
sunscreens to a garden in sydney during
spring
[Music]
the first thing we noticed when we
started looking through the camera
is that things that are made of
different materials and whether or not
they're in the sun
makes a massive difference a brown table
in the sun was 65 degrees
the stone in the shade was 7 degrees you
can see the color scale on the side
ignore the temperature in the middle
that's not always accurate we wrote down
the actual temperature numbers
the next thing i noticed was that things
that i didn't think would make a
difference
actually made a pretty big difference so
for example my arm near my elbow
was hotter than my arm near my wrist
that's because things that are closer to
the center of your body
are warmer because it's getting more
warmth from things like blood
i actually had a whole bunch of
sunscreens both chemical and physical on
my arm here
and you can't see any temperature
differences but you can see the
difference between the top of my arm and
the bottom of my arm
next i put a big black text mark on my
arm to see if it would make a difference
we all know that black things like to
absorb lots of visible light from the
sun
and heat up and there is a lot of
visible light in sunlight
so we thought this would be a really
good test to see what a thin
film of something that absorbs light and
produces heat really well would look
like on the skin
but again there just wasn't much of a
difference i'm pointing at the mark in
these photos and if you squint you can
just see it
but this does make sense humans are
about two-thirds water
water is special because it has a really
high specific heat capacity
that means it can absorb lots of heat
energy without itself heating up very
much
so basically your body is a huge heat
sink
a thin film of something producing heat
isn't producing very much heat your body
can easily absorb that and handle that
without itself heating up
[Music]
so we decided to get rid of the heatsink
and see if we could see any differences
without it
we applied two of the sunscreens one
chemical one physical onto
a thin piece of plastic well i applied
them while alex took random photos
at the start the chemical sunscreen was
actually four degrees colder
we figured it was because the sunscreens
were still drying and so
ethanol was evaporating from that
ethanol when it evaporates
cools down something significantly we
tried again 10 minutes later after
everything dried
and we found that the physical sunscreen
was one degree
colder but then we rotated the film by
180 degrees
and we found that the chemical sunscreen
was one degree colder
so it seems like the angle of the film
and the angle of the sun
makes a bigger difference than the type
of sunscreen so the plastic film i
liberated from a nearby construction
site was actually red and white
so we decided to just look at that
through the camera the red part of the
tape was actually six degrees hotter
than the white part
and so it seems like the color that
something is
makes a much bigger difference than
whether a sunscreen is chemical or
physical
for the final test i liberated a napkin
from a nearby restaurant
and i blobbed on nine different
sunscreens i had chemical sunscreens
physical sunscreens combo sunscreens
and even one that claimed to have ir
protection and cooling effects
again we waited 10 minutes for
everything to dry and then we looked
through the ir camera
the first thing we noticed was that the
tinted sunscreens were hotter than the
white ones
with the rest of the sunscreens there
wasn't really much of a pattern between
which ones are hot and cooler
in terms of whether they were physical
or chemical i was particularly
disappointed with the infrared one
i really expected that to have some sort
of noticeable difference
so these results make sense based on the
mechanism of how chemical and physical
sunscreens work and the law of
conservation of energy
there shouldn't really be much heat
produced at all and only the tiniest
difference between chemical and physical
sunscreens
and given how watery human bodies work
any heat that is produced should be
dissipated really really quickly it just
spreads into the rest of your body
there is a lot more visible light in
sunlight than there is uv
there can be more than 10 times as much
so it isn't surprising that things that
absorb visible light
heat up a lot more than things that
absorb uv so this is things like tinted
sunscreens and red tape
but even then when you do put it on your
skin because of that heatsink effect
there just isn't much of a difference
there was a much bigger difference
between the two parts of my arm than
with the black marker and no black
marker
so the difference in heat between
chemical and physical sunscreens
is insignificant there are other reasons
to pick chemical over physical or
physical over chemical
but the amount of heat produced just
shouldn't factor into your decision
making
after we did all this i actually found a
paper where some physicists
calculated how much a titanium dioxide
sunscreen would heat up your skin
they calculated 0.2 degrees celsius
so i hope that was a convincing
demonstration and hopefully that does
kill this myth a bit more
let me know what you think were you
surprised by these results i was
actually quite surprised i was actually
hoping that we would see something
interesting there would be some sort of
a difference but
i guess science works let me know if you
have any other topic suggestions in the
comments below
click the like and the subscribe if you
like my videos you can also check me out
on instagram at lab muffin beauty
science and my blog labmuffin.com
see you next time to nerd out more
you